مواجهه تنتهي بمقتل بطله تايكوندو تونسيه
فما القصه
حادثه اليمه هزت الشريعه التونسيه عاشت
على وقعها مدينه ليبيا من محافظه نابل حيث
لقيت بطله التايكواندو تصميم الغسلاتي
البالغه من العمر 16 عاما حتفها بينما
كانت تحاول التصدي لعمليه سرقه كان قد
تعرض لها محل احد الجيران
[موسيقى]
ووفق المعطيات الاوليه المتداوله فان
تسميم لاحظت خلال ليله الاثنين الماضي عند
خروجها للحديث بالهاتف امام منزلها حركه
غريبه في محل نجاره وعندما ذهبت الاستطلاع
الامر تبين لها ان شابا كان بصدد سرقه
المحل حاول التسنين التصدي للسارق وطلبت
منه ان يكف عن صنيعه وقام اللص الذي تبين
بانه من اصحاب السوابق العدليه بضربها
صحبه والده الذي كان برفقته بعصا على
راسها مما تسبب لهات نزيف داخلي ادى الى
وفاتها
الوحدات الامنيه تعرفت على القاتل الذي
تبين بانه من ساكني نفس الحي والقت القبض
عليه بينما ووريا جثمان تسنيم الوسلات
الثرى يوم الثلاثاء الماضي في جنازه
ماهيبه
وصفت والده الضحيه عبر تدوينه لها في موقع
التواصل الاجتماعي فيسبوك رحيله ابنتها
بالعمل البطولي وبالنهايه الماساويه لطفله
طالما عرفت بشجاعتها ودماثه اخلاقها
[موسيقى]